has improved every year as a store as
well and a terrific defendant for this
distance to help comes able to get again
into the lane how about the finish
through the contact by the potential MVP
of this means it is this is Reggie
Jackson that's a green quarter no
question they're gonna need a walk when
Jackson today
[Applause]
defensive backboard and he is a blur in
the open floor just puts tremendous
pressure on you the size the agility the
athleticism
and now let's add it on good as they've
been offensive Oh to spend what they've
been able to do defensively that's
allowed them the kind of blows
[Music]
James holding him out tonight and uh I'm
not sure he would have made much of a
difference till this point not with the
way the games other thing about Blake
though is in the problem for this
Pistons team into the corner to Galloway
I tend to pass with the Julia broken up
by Sterling Brown on the train there in
[Applause]
everyone knows the numbers 70% shooter
inside the paintings only 29% outside
the paint in terms of his field goal we
set it to Nellie's again that's where
he's not in rhythm you see here just
great patience by Bledsoe weak side
defense account late in part because it
they're worried about the three-point
shooting weak side so you just five
straight threes to begin the third
quarter comes again
[Applause]
Oh God waiting down to the Pistons did
you see where he took off oh my goodness
he really is a freak physically that guy
and I'm telling you just take off just
my goodness and thatís was as Donna's
economist he was the man out that I
can't even get my thoughts straight Don
was trying to split up the block that
Lopez finds Yanis he sees a wall nothing
goes down
Garrus
boys Justin Wetzel steps in father's
side
958 French don't break play yeah and let
so just kind of flooding the passing
lane active hands and they were down is
that they've been knocked out has
presented some issues for the Bucs held
a bus to what 20 points did the comb
ball look at this this Smith thinks he
has a wide open land and out of nowhere
ah John dinner lands and it rolls right
back to strain bra oh my goodness
this is unbelievable we're witness I
mean the same time
the extension the length and how about
at the end of it the concentration make
them say Connaughton with the bullet may
have to lift up the floor here manana
Snoop Dogg place position on Hayward
the mom this is just I've got to come
here watch the push-off there it is
there that created the space to enable
him to catch the pass which was you know
according to the referee on that that
was okay
[Applause]
[Music]
this is what we've all been waiting to
see Stretch Armstrong coming through the
left hand have to see much of it plus
four
you see Mars and Venus I mean I think
we've seen this dr. J I'm gonna give him
that fish eight of the last nine
putting at home on a nice skin how do
you stop this bin
the footwork of Jana is so underrated
Middleton got it back on the given goal
10 Akula on the pearl ha got all the way
to the bucket with those long stride its
minutes ago in the third the third
quarter has been the deciding quarter in
each of these games so far
tights block great great pass down
inside and in a terrific block earlier
so Val Jenna cook those spins on Loras
whistle and run on tentacle goal Jana
said asbestos watch out how about this
stepping in just a little finger roll so
some great
Middleton hits it out to attend a
football night show and go by Yanis on
the body of a Greek god and the
execution of an NBA MVP say they can't
catch some they got 10 much quick
Tenneco flow with 12 rebounds 27 points
8 assists and one more foot for the real
III I've got a bright by Irving Denton
where's the double-team in Game one it
was so impressive because they did it
for 48 minutes covering on the baseline
she might have been a little premature
on that her diction or that at that time
they're in a little 1-3-1 zone by jana
how about that one
in that position down three games to one
isn't it pull it out where's your honest
were looking for the honest I love the
way the buds play they play always keep
[Applause]
[Music]
me honest puts the balls on offer
[Applause]
plus the foul again it should not be
understated and I know that wilt and
other players have done this but since
recording this stack of points in the
paint
gentlemen ground accelerating
[Applause]
the tipsters rebound
we're losing all the hustle plays well
look at this they are not losing this
hustle play and to the cupola confident
with the rebound for coffee you want to
Celtics to attack the glass they have
second chance
[Applause]
pain poster they say you should get a
jump shot shoot 53 games
[Applause]
mom you said it Connie Hawkins he said a
little bit of dr. Chang waking his
speech but he said simply we have to
make tweaks before we commit and go
[Music]
[Applause]
let's get better in let's go heroes hey
we're going back pretty much as far as
this game came into the forge time of
the Celtics except they don't have any
inside scored 40 pilla Phoenix on sale
another Jerry Colangelo higher
[Applause]
[Music]
28% 21 to 74 from the field so the foul
so good to play the players you just
throw it up to and before the Raptors
they have to get back to build that wall
and Reggie I'm so surprised at how much
margin
[Applause]
here's the steal hereby be honest no one
in the black jerseys even wants to run
with them in his definied Game seven
against Philadelphia in Game seven a
seat that the left has were reluctant to
take
look at this this is not a Euro step I
mean he is talking about being quiet
where Jonathan Jacobo as well
the Irish goddess
[Applause]
was the Greek freak while traveling down
the lane here one release that
conference partner put billed as an
averaging only eight points in these
playoffs
[Applause]
to sneak a layup and get one quick
taking the best shot available right no
sneaking around young to greet him Kyle
Lowry
Yanis talked about it the buck shape
like they complete better and that's
because of the leather football
- the files run able to hip on that
straight away jumper there is Yanis to
the lane downhill just goes right by
Tiago with a pretty good defender
himself build the contact look at all
the black jerseys around 210 gone by
here in the fourth quarter
Yanis get it
no pets gone with it off to the rim and
driving attacking tons of contact no
call recovery by honest to make the
block she's right there he get the
contact and go off easily could have
been two free throws for Pascal sake
[Applause]
the couple once again
[Applause]
vulnerable from the half-court iana's
back-to-back buckets trying to bring the
bluffs back pace Nicotiana he gets the
rebound he's taken in himself being
aggressive double-teams
and he lost to them second consecutive
turnover and here's got us all the way
sweeping around Gasol zone also has not
shot the three well neither Club did the
other night got the step out of strip
Gasol pushed off the post right there
and I like him in that position because
the double-team let's so what to save
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
no the Greek freak in transition with
the left hand
Yanis off to a strong start with the
left hand
Yanis off to a strong start
[Applause]
give me the Dutch particularly well
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
out of three the other night
that's the way to make sure I go tell
you what when he is going downhill
because if you do not he will take off
don't go on you and you can print that
poster you know
play by siakam so gives it up
[Music]
knows that there's a switch as well
Gasol played it correct to seven of nine
from downtown
Qantas what the alley
water coolant has given go one here
[Applause]
- cuckoo by the walki siakam going in
he'll see after all he is rejected by
identical dog but help side deepest
trust your teammates and to the cocoa
swats that out of bounds
[Applause]